welcome back to 8701
so in this lecture i'd like you um to
have a first connection
between particle physics and the
laplacian formalism in classical
mechanics you have seen that you can
write down the lagrangian using the
kinetic and the potential energy of a
particle and
from that derive equations of motions
in quantum field theory you can
translate this idea
and derive lagrangian densities
it's beyond the scope of this class to
you know do all the mechanics of this
we revisit this topic later
um in the class when we introduce the
higgs mechanism for example
and there'll be a little bit more
systematic then
um i'm introducing the topic now because
it allows you to answer
one of the homework questions so you can
just follow this lecture and then you
should be able to
answer on you know the first question of
the second preset
all right um so
you just have to trust me at this point
that you can write the question for
feed the direct field or lagrangian
density for
direct field this way um one exercise
would be
to use this and show that this is like
from this lagoon you can derive the
debug equation
for a spinner field but that's not what
we're trying to do here we're trying to
see what the effect is of um having this
lagrange density being
invariant or unchanged under global
symmetry
so we are able to rotate our spinal
field
with a global phase and we will see that
the lagrangian doesn't change
and there's a consequence of this which
is the free current this is exercising
uh neuter theory there's an overarching
global symmetry
and out of the symmetry follows the
conserve property
in this case the current all right
so we can express this symmetry
with infinite infinitesimal phase
transformation as shown here
for our fields and for our adjunct
fields
um for the field and the derivative then
we just you know have to do the math and
we find you know those expressions
which we can then put back into our log
function
first of all we write the um the change
of our lagrangian
um in this way and as we just i've seen
the lagrangian
is invariant under this um this
transformation and therefore
the change is going to be zero so when
we use this information
at this in the equations we find this
very complicated looking
set of equations okay so now we get this
um and then we can
rewrite the terms um so this is already
with a vision of what we would like to
actually
find later so if we
if we
now look at the terms involving the
derivative with respect to
the mu of our spinner spinner um
we can express this equations as as
shown here
and with that we find the next equation
um i only show this for the
for the for the spinner not for the jump
spinner this looks exactly the same
but you however find in this part here
this looks like euler lagrange equation
and this part needs to be zero
so we only have to worry about this part
of the equation and the same for the
juncture
so this then leaves this equation here
where we have
i epsilon derivative of this part of the
equation
and something like this you have seen
before
in our continuity equation something
like this
um it's our continuing education we
discussed this in one of the last
visitation session
which leads us into conserved currents
and let's go one step further
if we now identify this part as
our our current we can
we can then use the partial derivatives
of our initial lagrangian and we're just
calculating
those terms here and we find that our
current
our conserved current is given by the
spinner
and so what we have just seen and this
is conserved so the derivative is zero
um we've seen that we have a lagrangian
density
we have a global symmetry and out of
that
we find that the current is conserved
so this is all i wanted to show here in
the homework set now
we start from a different lagrangian so
this is the
lagrangian for a massive spin half
particle
which satisfies the dirac equation in
the homework we are looking at
a scalar particle a muscle scalar
particle and the exercise however is
very much the same